how can we quickly square the numbers
that are close to 50 let's see 53
squared here the base is 50. in the
first step we will subtract the base
from the number so 53 minus 50 gives us
3 let us divide the answer into two
parts on the left we write 25 plus the
difference which is 3 so 25 plus 3 on
the right we will write the square of
the difference hence we will write 3
squared the answer is 2 8 0 9. what will
48 squared be equal to using similar
logic 48 minus 50 gives us negative 2 on
the left side we will write 25 plus
negative 2 on the right side we will
write negative 2 the whole square
remember that there are only two digits
on the right side on the left we get 23
and on the right we get 0 4. yours our
answer
using this trick can you tell us the
value of 51 squared in the comment
section for more such interesting math
concepts do hit the subscribe button